uh good good day uh this is um
the stanford university uh
ee380 computer systems colloquial
today we're talking about the
microprocessor
the very first one the
intel 4004
with people who um were there at the
time
which is uh we think
an interesting exercise because
um lots of
lots of war stories have come out of the
out of the
microprocessor
and this particular one which is quite
legendary
uh in any case the uh
the primary uh
lead off will be stan mazer who is uh
one of the
designers or
architects of the
processor along with ted hoff and
federico feijin
when it was done at intel in the uh
early september excuse me early 70s
uh stan you want to say hello
hi there
great
and then um
you know we have uh we have um
uh
two uh software people that's me and uh
uh tom pittman uh tom and uh and i um
both have the uh
uh the privilege of writing assemblers
for the uh for the systems uh he did one
for the development board and i did one
for the uh
microprocessor development system
and uh we'll have uh some things to say
about programming uh programming the
4004 which was
an experience for each of us
uh tom you say hello
is that a big enough hello
that's fine okay
tom went on and did there's a whole
bunch of stuff uh you know our our
careers have have intertwined a great
deal uh he did i did a tiny basic for
when we were i was at pcc and uh dr dobs
journal
and uh tom went on later and did
did more piney basic and then more tiny
basic and so forth uh and so um you know
our careers paths have
crossed over many times
ed lee um
was one of the users of the uh
the machine he had a company in
monterey which took a lot of the parts
and uh made them into useful uh useful
devices uh his partner matt muir and uh
others
were
a
a long-standing a cylinder
microprocessor workshop tradition
where we would uh
he would extol the virtues of uh
programming uh in absolute octal or
absolute hex as opposed to uh other
here's assembly language
oh yeah that was that was a that was a
crutch you were supposed to be able to
look at f3 and know what it
i means a lot of that but i didn't write
into excess
there was a point i could actually write
large pieces of code with uh you know in
hexadecimal but it's gone now
um and then um i think that that's our
our panel for the for the time
uh stan has prepared a a little uh
uh
a set of slides and uh some talk about
uh the context here and so i'm
i'll leave it to him
and uh
when he's when he comes to the end we'll
uh we'll talk about some of the war
stories and so forth um we all have uh
have things which uh it would be nice to
capture for the uh for the history of
nothing else
so stan are you ready
yes and thank you very much dennis i
have prepared the 15 slides and it'll
probably take a little over 25 minutes
and i'll click over to them now
i am 80 years old and i retired after 6
40 years of work and uh i've highlighted
those points and i'm going to be slicing
the time from 1960
to
1975 some of the related events for
microprocessors during that time and
i'll be covering very briefly my
attendance at san francisco state
i will mention fairchild and then the
15 years that i was at intel i'll go in
a little bit more detail
so
in 1963
i was in san francisco state university
there was a single computer on the
campus
and it was the ibm 1620
that's a picture of it which had a
select direct typewriter for input and
output on the right hand side
and a punch card reader and punch
generally speaking it was a serial
decimal
machine it could do a 10 digit add in
about one millisecond
it probably cost something on the order
of a million dollars but they were
mainly
at least
it had a core memory and
when you powered up it took about five
minutes for the core to be warm enough
to be usable
and it was a von neumann architecture in
that we had both data and program in the
same core memory
um
interesting thing about this machine are
the components that i'll be speaking
about very briefly that came from ibm
the standard module system ibm was
probably the largest manufacturer of
transistors in the united united states
and perhaps the world
and one of the high cost items in a
computer was the transistors
now
if i ask you what is three plus five
you'll look it up in your memory and
you'll come up with an eight
if i ask you what's three
five plus three you'll come up with the
same answer
well this computer we called cadet can't
add doesn't even try
in other words an editor would require
several dozen transistors and it had no
adder and no arithmetic unit
but in memory location 353
there was an eight
and in memory location
335 there was an eight so when you did
the add instruction it took the two
digits and went to the table in core
memory and retrieved the decimal answer
that's why we called it cadet and that
was in order to save transistors which
were so expensive in those days
now the multiply was done with a table
of 200 digits so of course as long as
core memory was loaded with the add
table and multiply table you could do
arithmetic
now ibm announced this machine at the
same time as their 1401
and the ibm 1620 was designed and built
in san jose so just like many companies
you have a battle between east versus
west
and they did not want the 1620 to
compete with the 1401
so the 1620 could have no magnetic tape
and if there's anything that you would
notice about 1401 ibm installations is
they had a lot of magnetic tape so the
markets were separated by marketing for
that reason although they were built
with the same components
by
1960s half the computers in the world
were ibm
1401s
and because of the consent decree which
came out in 1956
ibm people were very careful about
how they
handled their domination of the market
we jokingly called them ibm and the
seven dwarfs that was the bunch
burrows univac ncr control data
honeywell ge and rca
it is notable that digital equipment did
not make computers
as we all know
they made
pdp
programmed data processors so they
certainly weren't in the computer
business and sun only made workstations
so they weren't in the computer business
either
now what's significant to me is that ted
hoff at stanford erl also had a 1620 so
our computer experience in programming
and working computers were very parallel
when we came together later on
now speaking of the ibm
systems they were using the sms card
which i show here in the picture
that
card is about the same size as a playing
card uh deck of cards six transistors
typically it only had a single side of
wire and they were pluggable into the
connector and on the back panel at the
bottom is how the cards were wired
together so both the 1620 and this
1401 were built with a single standard
module system now
by
1965 ibm's technology had
gone tremendously further to what they
called solid-state solid logic
technology this is an aluminum substrate
one inch square
face down bonding
and of course
it could put
integrating components including silicon
chips and other kinds of things on it
and the 360 of course was their huge big
product you may remember model 30 model
40 50 60
and uh fairchild where i worked had both
those machines where i learned to
program
the 1401
the 360
also the
sds 930
i then went from personally at fairchild
to
design
and work on the simple computer which
was a high level language computer and
where i learned to do logic design and
for floating point
now i want to jump to
integrated circuits
what we call large scale integrated
circuits and review for a moment
some of the fundamentals that were
confronting us being in that business at
fairchild and then at intel
first of all the tooling cost
making masks and other requirements were
quite costly so to build an lsi chip for
a
usual case you needed a high product
volume
with a custom chip or if it was a
standard part a very large market for
that ship to make it feasible
among the considerations was the cost of
design
and the complexity of the design
when i was at intel it was one man did
one ship
i imagine today if you go into a chip
design company there's either hundreds
or thousands of people working on a
single chip
so the ability of doing a design and the
cost had a lot to do with how complex it
was
other issues were the amount of on-chip
wiring how much wire is there and how
difficult is it to wire different items
on that chip
furthermore
for every pin on the package if it's an
output it needs a lot of area for the
driver circuit and every pin is going to
have a pad
so
besides the cost of the silicon increase
because of pins
the pins on the package and the size of
the package was a major cost and this
will become more relevant when i'm
describing the mcs-4
and lastly of course
which we will talk a little bit about
moore's law
the larger the chip the lower the yield
the higher the cost and then therefore
the higher the price
so in 1970 we had high voltage pmos
and there were two particular markets
that were interesting
the glass teletype that is the crt
terminal which needed memory to store
the data on the screen
and high volume electronic consumer
products such as desk calculators
the early
vendors of pmos circuits
tended to have at least these two kinds
of products
the shift register
let me speak about that for a moment
it's about nine transistors per bit
having designed a single bit if you have
a 100 bit shift register you have just
copied
those nine transistors a hundred times
the wiring in a shift register each bit
only has to talk to its nearest neighbor
so there is essentially no wiring issue
except for power and ground and clocks
and lastly when you put it in a package
it could go in a t05
five pin package which is very cheap and
importantly it had one bit in and one
bit out
so the shift register meets the
requirements that i've just mentioned
one the design cost is low the on-chip
wiring is simple the package is cheap
and the yield is the only question do
you make a hundred bits or 200 bits or
whatever so shift registers were the
ideal product and they were used in crt
terminals to store the bit serial data
the other
chip is a rom and a read-only memory is
programmed in the factory with a mask
for a particular customer so now you
only go into this business if your
customer is going to buy a lot of them
he pays for them
for the set of them and you're
guaranteed that you can sell it to
somebody so the custom chip was probably
a rom and the standard chip was probably
a shift register
and it was probably in 16 pins or fewer
with one layer of metal
by the way the
popular
terminals you might remember was a
company called beehive and there were at
least five other companies making the
first crt
terminals
so let's jump over now to um moore's law
that's a picture of dr moore who is now
living in the big island of hawaii
and he made this observation
which became ultimately a promise
and i wouldn't really say it was the law
but this is actually what he noticed the
horizontal axis is density it's the
number of transistors on a chip and i
have added the letters ssi for small
scale
msi for medium scale
and lsi for large scale
and that corresponds with 10 transistors
100 transistors and 1 000 transistors
and what he has on the vertical
scale is cost and there that doesn't
matter too much if it's pennies or
dollars the main point is that he
projected the following
if the chip is too large the cost starts
to go up so we call this a
bathtub curve and when you're designing
you are trying to reach something that
is at the bottom of that curve in that
little u-shaped thing
so since i was in design
we were always projecting what's the
cost going to be two years from now or
three years from now in other words when
you're in high volume production that's
when you want to have your minimal cost
so you have to have a forecast of what's
going to be ahead of you which is
precisely why dr moore drew this chart
starting in 62 he had experience at
fairchild in 65
and and started to predict for the next
generation and he came up with this idea
that the cost is going to go down
dramatically as the density goes up
now in the years that i was in
semiconductors people did not understand
this and they came out with the
following kinds of concept they wanted
to build something which was 60
transistors or 600 transistors which was
too small and not interested interesting
or on the contrary they wanted to build
something with 60 000 transistors which
was out of the question
so the secret of this business was to
really grasp moore's law the business
you were in
now if i need to make one chip for a
spaceship i could process thousands of
wipers to get one chip
but in the commercial business
where you're dealing with customer
products
then this is the real world and the cost
is a major consideration
so i'm going to say that when we were
working in ship design we were always
counting transistors
package pins
and those kinds of things so i we can
come back to moore's law a little later
if if i haven't said enough about that
now this is a sordid wafer it's uh got
ink on it because in these days
we put the wafer under a tester which
probes came down and actually exercised
each individual die
and
detected shorts between power and ground
and if the chips seemed to be defective
it was marked with an ink
spot
and then if the chip seemed to be okay
then it was not marked
now after this the next step is to dice
the wafer
into little pieces and to put each good
one
into a package solder on the leads throw
away the bad ones they're of no use
and then you could test
the chip at high speed where it really
has to work we could not do high-speed
testing when we were probing on the
wafer itself
now what's interesting about this wafer
and it's just to give you some visual
idea this is probably on the order of 60
percent good die
and i can't actually have counted up and
it's not terribly important but you
might actually in some business be
okay with 10 good yield and there are
some businesses if you're making
something for mattel toy or maybe you
needed to get 90
so it's a very business issue as to
predict the yield and then to know the
market you're in
and ultimately to work to improve that
yield
now in the ab stack and this depends on
what you're you're in
it's about 300 processing steps as many
as 20 photographic steps it could take
as long as three months to make
but why are things bad what a silly
business is can you imagine making cars
and saying you have to throw away 40
of your cars because they fail
what kind of business is this where you
have to throw away 40 or 50 percent
and the answer is well
the basic wafers themselves may have
defects and then you can't make anything
good at it or your processing is not
perfect a hundred percent on every step
if you ever tried to put together the
product of several hundred processing
steps with each one being 99
good you'd be absolutely amazed to know
what the f
fallout rate is
so we're talking about statistical
limits
and of course when you make wafers you
make them in batches maybe 10 or 20 at a
time
and
in the end you have to test each die on
the wafer get the good ones and and
process them
so that's the
quick view of
the idea of moore's law now what i'd
like you to do if you can just imagine
choose any four of these squares
and draw sort of in your mind a square
around them and you'll notice as the dye
gets larger your imaginary dye which is
four times larger
it is more likely that it will pick up a
defect
so if it was four times larger which
simply means twice as wide and twice as
tall
then
it's more likely to not work because it
it has an element of it that doesn't
work
now when the dye is twice as large you
get half as many die on the wafer and so
already you've reduced the possible
yield by half of that
and of course
as i'll tell you right now if you
improve the size increase the size by 25
your yield will fall in half
that's a very good first estimate a
little bit bigger and your yield goes
down really steep so we're talking about
geometric curves although it depends on
the process
how complicated it is and what the
defects are like in addition to that so
there's a quick view of
using moore's law on a semiconductor
wafer now of course we take the chip and
we put it in a package and this shows
where the die has been soldered into a
ceramic package and the bonding wires
are individually applied in those days
by hand with a soldering machine and
there's a little wire that goes from
every pad on the die to
ultimately the pin on the package
in
part of the cost is the assembly cost
part of the cost is that the chip that
was good isn't good when it's in the
package because it doesn't run at speed
and then there's the cost of the package
which is non-trivial in the case of a
ceramic package 16 pin cost about a
dollar
i'm talking about in those days in a
plastic package cost about 25 cents
now it's not unusual for manufacturers
to charge twice whatever their cost is
so if this is what the package cost us
you can imagine the selling price was
increased by at least twice
that
amount now this kind of package was
invented by the team i was in at
fairchild it's called the dual inline
package or dip and what we mean by that
is the two rows of pins eight on each
side or seven on each side
are in line and they are rigid and
there's two sets of them so it's dual
in-line package and that was the main
package that we were using for
integrated circuits
and if it was a 24 pin package it would
be two and a half dollars if it was a 40
pin package it could be five or six
dollars so the package cost as i said
is not only the area of the die for
attaching the wires but it's the cost of
the package itself
now i want to go to the busycom
calculator which is one of our main
focuses in the discussion today
one of the markets for custom chips
and one of the driving forces the main
one for our first microcomputer was this
printing desktop calculators
now in the 50s everybody owned an adding
machine and the adding machine may not
have been electronic
but on an adding machine you can't do
multiply very well and divide is super
difficult
so what you want is a four function
calculator to do add subtract multiply
and divide
and if you're in any kind of accounting
field you need a printed record of it
because after you have done a
computation
you need to tear off the paper and check
what is on that paper and prove that you
didn't push the wrong button and you got
the right answers
so this printer has a ribbon on it
the ribbon is red and black because it
was common practice as with typewriters
that a negative result was printed in
red and a positive
was printed in black
now if you look at the printed circuit
board you're going to see the 4004 and
the rom and ram on the right hand side
in those dip packages
but you're going to see a slew of
transistors
to drive the solenoid hammers for the
printer
so the point was the solenoids required
enough power and energy that you could
not really include those drivers on the
integrated circuit chip
so this is the one board that you'll see
sitting in the calculator
and now i want to focus instead on what
these chips did and what the program had
to do
the keyboard
required a matrix of 4x4 four rows by
four columns and you continuously
scanned to look for a key depression
when you had a result to be printed the
printer had a rotary drum and the timing
was such that you had to fire a hammer
at the right time to hit the zero or one
or two as the drum was rotating so the
printing control had to be done by
software in the computer
and of course this thing did floating
point arithmetic
of 16 digits and that consisted of 20
digit numbers four digits for the
exponent and 16 digits for the mantissa
and it had to do floating point
so this was the task and the actual
implementation was one
chip which is the ceramic chip where the
arrow is there the 4004
and it had four roms because it took a
thousand bytes of code to do this job
and there was one pro run ram
which gave us
four
registers of 20 digits in other words
four floating point numbers
now let me just back off and say that mr
shima
was my office mate
and he came from japan
and he knew about the calculator and
this was his project and he was looking
for chips to do that
my other office mate
after shema left was mr fajim and fajin
was the designer who did all of the
logic design circuit design layout and
and implemented all those chips
in the pmos
silicon gate process
the architecture for
this system came from ted hoff my boss
and when i joined him in september of
he had already conceived of this project
and i joined him and i'll talk about the
kinds of things that i did
but this is important as this was the
driver for our
project and this then became a standard
microprocessor
let me say that our contract did not
allow us to sell these parts to any
other cap any other calculator company
and we got the idea of selling these as
a general purpose project
after we got into the project of water
now the 4004 is the central processor
and
ted and i had both programmed the ibm
1620 which could do a call instruction
with only one
memory
of the
where you left so you could only do one
call you could not do nested calls so
based on the 1620
we came up with the idea of a four
level stack or really you could have
three nested calls and that instruction
in the list is called the jms jump to
subroutine and it had a 12-bit address
because that's what we would design the
system to handle
uh 4 000 um
12 12
12 bits of address the jump
unconditional instruction was also a two
byte instruction and it has the jump to
a 12-bit address
the conditional jump at the top as in
many computers we had conditional jumps
and it was a relative jump to um
something on what we'd call the same
page or in the same rom and it had an
8-bit address
so these are highlights some of the
instructions that were in the 4000 4004
now ted and i had programmed the ibm
1620 and ted and i had programmed the
dec pdp-8
the accumulator group we lifted almost
wholesale out of the pdp8 in other words
clear accumulator complement accumulator
and so on so the accumulator group was
more or less copied
uh a bunch of these instructions are
obvious things that you need inside of a
computer add and subtract
let me emphasize the program counter as
we called it that we now call the
instruction pointer was 12 bits
and we thought this was going to be
inadequate enough for most of our
applications
now two instructions that i added
this is first of all what we call a
modified harvard architecture and let
remind you that in the von neumann
machine you have
data and program in the same memory but
here we're going to emphasize that you
cannot execute program out of ram
and
one of our first problems that i
encountered is we couldn't have a way of
getting data out of rom that was the
program memory so i suggested
since we had done table lookup in the
1620 and that was its basics for doing
arithmetic i said if we're going to have
table up we ought to be able to use the
rom for that so i specifically added the
fetch indirect instruction
since i wanted to build an interpreter
or a virtual machine i needed that i
might need a way of jumping somewhere
indirectly so we added the jump indirect
so ted had done the architecture i had
come up with two or three smaller issues
and these were two instructions that i
had added and
that was the significance of part of my
project participation on this
machine
now
it's easy to say that this story is
about a 4-bit
cpu and i believe that is a major
mistake
because the significance of this project
wasn't so much the 4-bit cpu
but that there were three chips that
worked together
and when i go back to the subject of
pins and cost it is a major point to
make out right here
that the rom and the ram and the cpu had
a 4-bit data bus
that means a 12-bit program counter had
to use the 12-bit data bus the 8-bit
instructions had to use the 4-bit data
bus
and so this is
a ridiculous decision in computer
architecture except
if the pins are very expensive
and the logic is very cheap
then you slow down the processor
to use fewer pins
and
let me emphasize a couple of points that
are not at all obvious that i think are
some of the brilliant parts of this
architecture
a memory chip has a read com line and a
right line because you have to read and
write into the ram
this ram absolutely does not have a read
and write line
how could that be
the next point
is every ram has four bits of output
which means the computer has to send
four bits of data to the ram chip to put
out
there is no pin
on this package that says get ready for
some data that's coming to send to your
port
the rom has four input output pins
programmed by mask you can choose as the
user whether you want a pin to be output
there is also no wire that goes to this
chip that says you're getting data to go
out or getting data to come in how is
that possible
and the answer is simply brilliant
when the op code
appears
on the four-bit bus
coming out of the rom the ram looks at
the bus and says what are we going to do
oh we're going to do a read port or a
right port or a read ram or a right ram
so the seat the ram chip it's not a ram
chip
the ram chip is a chip which also has an
instruction decoder to look at the bus
and see what operation the cpu wants to
perform
and when the rom fetches the instruction
it could certainly be an instruction
that has to do with some other rom and
its port but when the op code comes on
the bus all the roms look at the
instruction that's being fetched and
sent to the cpu
and says what are we doing next
so that's such a clever thing
is that with a multiplex bus
all the chips can look at the opcode and
know what operation is being performed
so i want to emphasize this is not just
a smart cpu this is an integrated set of
three chips
so again let's just look quickly at the
slide here in the first three cycles
four bits each 12-bit program counter
goes to rom
and eight bits of that are stored in
each rom chip in its memory address
register
in the next two
cycles one of the roms response because
it saw its chip select code and he knows
who he is because it's encoded on his
chip and only one of the roms of the
possible 12 respond with the instruction
and it it's an eight bit up eight bit so
it takes two cycles and then there are
three execution cycles so we have a time
slice bus
and uh four bits go across at a time and
in this case we have
the ability of doing a 10 digit
decimal ad in about a millisecond
at about a hundred dollar cost
and the important thing is that ted and
i had used the 1620 and it did an ad
in a millisecond and it cost a million
dollars
and so the point was could we do
with a computer that we had used about
the same job
with a few chips for what turned out to
be a hundred dollars and that was the
real goal of the
mcs-4
and one would not criticize the mcs-4
because it was slow you would say the
mcs-4 was cheap
now in 69 i met with data point and also
known as computer terminals
and it turns out they were interested in
an 8-bit problem and they were
interested in 8-bit chips 8-bit
things like that and they had no idea of
the idea of doing a central processor
so we
simply asked the question could we build
their processor and it turns out i saw
them in december and in march i wrote
this specification for the 8008 and i
wrote it in pencil you have to laugh but
that's how i wrote it and i passed it to
my boss ted hoff who took out an eraser
and you'll see where i've circled two
words 10 and seven
because i was talking about programmer
visible registers and ted wanted to
correct it for the actual number of
registers
on the chip
so
i wrote it in pencil he erased it
changed two words and it got sent
ultimately to data point
and what were our issues about building
an 8-bit cpu well
the die size
the power dissipation the package pin
count
its testability and so on so at the same
time we are working on the 4004 we were
working on the 8008 and so both
microprocessors came out at about the
same time and i'll get to that in a
moment
now the small war story was we were
doing this chip for computer terminals
so we didn't patent it
but that was all right texas instrument
patented this chip
now you don't have to be a lawyer to
know to get a patent it has to be
feasible it has to be reduced to
practice or reducible to practice but
the clever thing to understand is you
don't have to be one
that does it
so texas instrument patent the intel
8008 and the feasibility was that intel
could make it
so
we did not patent it and i have to tell
you when you bought the 8008 you needed
to pay
texas instrument
a royalty on their patent
this chip was designed by hal feni
hal was an office made of mine and
worked for fujine at the time and fagin
managed this project after he finished
working on the 4004 and i'm sure he gave
a lot of help to hal
because it architecture are almost
identical
in the broadest sense so here we can
talk a little bit
about this chip
well it has registers and it has seven
registers by eight which is 56 bits
and guess what the 4004 had 16 registers
of four bits so the registers aren't
particularly any bigger
the program stack is uh let's say 8 deep
and 14 bits wide but on the 4004 it was
12 beats wide and
40.
the instruction decoder doesn't care
whether you're decoding a 4-bit
instruction a piece
an instruction for 4004 or an
instructions thousand for an 8008 so we
could sort of make a guess that the
instruction decoder would be the same
size uh as a about the 4004 the register
section would be slightly bigger but the
big difference is in the aou if you down
look down below that's the 8-bit
arithmetic unit and it has a ripple
carry adder when you draw a ripple carry
adder on a circuit diagram it's usually
in the shape of a triangle if you look
right at the bottom of the picture you
will see the carry ripple carrier which
is a diagonal or triangle so of course
the 8-bit aou
would be bigger
and
i made a couple of decisions on this
chip i ended up with what we call little
indian i did that for a reason that i
don't need to disclose here but in
retrospect that was a mistake
i changed the program counter to be just
14 bits instead of 16 because i wanted
to get two pins
uh where time division the multiplying a
multiplexing a bus i needed some more
pins so by reducing the program counter
to 14 bits which i thought was adequate
i was able to use two pins for signals
something else
and this chip ended up to be about a
half a watt
now
we didn't know if we could build the
but by the time we got to working on the
8008 we had a
pretty good guess of its feasible and we
estimated that the chip would be
acceptable in size and so that was how
we went ahead with the 8008 i do need to
say that we built it for data point they
never bought one
and so that was a completely failed
project for data point
here's the two chips side by side it's
important because they were the same
generation and in the same technology
one's in a 16 package it's 16 pin the
other is an 18
and roughly speaking
the 8008 was 25 larger
and probably roughly double the cost and
therefore the price might have been
about the same so here we're bringing
moore's law into practice and you can
imagine how important it was in our
pretty good estimate before we committed
the resources to build another central
processor
by the time we got to the 8080 we did do
a patent on that and the fajin did that
chip with shima who did the actual logic
i did the architecture for it and i did
256 instructions
16th from the bottom on my instruction
set was exchange top of stack with h l
when shima got to that instruction
he drew a red line under it and said
no more
so who designed the 8080 well
sheamus said no more so the last of my
16 instructions did not go into it which
left room on the 8085 for some other
instructions
and of course
fajine managed the project and
supervised it and chima did the actual
layout
and so in this case ted was not so
involved in it and he's not on this
particular patent but i assure you ted
was the genius that got us into the
microprocessor business to start with
and fijine
did all these chips either himself or
supervised them let me mention also he
developed two things in the
semiconductor process something called
the buried contact that allowed us to
run polysilicon wires
in more places and also the bootstrap
amplifier which gives us a dynamic
charge
to improve performance
so
now looking at the big picture if you
would have extrapolated the performance
increase
in the first
years
uh you would have a certain slope and
then this is the performance and cpus
over about 10 years or more
due to improvements in technology and
instruction set as we went to the 8086
and so on
so in the ieee we have a document called
the annals of computer history i have
written uh some articles to follow up on
my personal interest
uh on the 4004 on the 8008
on the 8080 and the 8086.
sixth i worked on the symbol uh
high-level language computer i have an
article on that and i worked on video
games we had a chip for magnavox i was
working on that for a year in that
project and those are some of the
articles that i've written so that's my
introduction and i hope that's suitable
uh for our discussion uh today
sounds great
[Music]
please go ahead
okay
um i think that the next thing i would
like to do is um
explain exactly
one thing
and that is um
where we all stand
um tom are you still around
yes i'm here okay i just didn't want to
be interrupting him
that's fine
the question is what is it that you did
on the on the uh uh
4004 because you were you you were i
think there
prior to the point i was because you
worked on the uh development board i
believe
uh yes um i uh
in high school i wanted my own computer
and when i saw the intel ad in uh i
don't know i think it was
one of the uh news
industry newsletter papers double page
ad nicest i want one so i went to the
seminar it was in the spring of
72.
and they talked about uh how how it
worked and how the they had an assembler
that ran on the
on to the pdp 10 and
so i raised my hand i says
do you have a resident assembler
and uh you know the run's on the chip
and they said talk to us afterward
so i traded a i traded an assembler for
a
uh
their their larger
uh emulation board they had a small one
with four wrong slot sockets and a big
one with the full address space and i
got the large one and a rum burner and i
had to buy my own teletype
um
i
wrote it in assembly language compiled
it on yeah assembled it on there pdp 10
but eventually i got it working on on my
on my computer
and uh
didn't use the pdp 10 anymore
that was a i had to get the assembler to
fit in the four-rom socket uh smaller
board
so i had 1k
to work with
and uh
you probably know
it uh
there wasn't any space for tables so i
did a hash code on the up codes
uh if the hash was correct
uh basically i
did the hash
looked in that byte of memory
and that was the app code that the uh
that the three letters uh hashed to
and then i did a second hash
and looked in that byte of memory and if
the i don't remember what the algorithm
was if it was
uh a suitable hash for an op code then i
decided it was not an error a typing
error
i
did not do character for character
compare it was a hash code lookup
and uh usually the bytes that i was
fetching to to do the uh
to do the op code fetch you know
compares those were instructions as part
of the interpreter
and the uh and the check byte was also a
part of the code
so i had some
jiggling to do to
come up with a uh perfect hash so that
it
so that it got all the instructions
out of memory without uh tying up table
space
and uh
it was a chore it took a while
they came to me they wanted to do the 40
40. i said no way
it was unmaintainable
well it's it's it's fascinating because
it's it's another example of
the difference the programming has how
programming has changed
we no longer try to make the smallest
fastest code we possibly can we make the
uh well we worry a little bit about
speed but we don't worry about size
memory is really considered free right
and so we don't worry about
squeezing things into a thousand bytes
or
4 000 bytes or
whatever
and
in a sense there's a whole
a whole brand of programming a way of
thinking about programs which uh
has uh has really escaped to
escape everybody these days
yeah
you still you still feel the the burden
of uh big programs because it takes
longer for your page to load
yes
but you know i think i think that you
look at the tiny basic issue you know
where
yeah the uh 8080 was uh delivered as a
machine
uh by altair
and it came with uh 4k bytes of memory
and
no no no it had 256 bytes you had to buy
the
the 4k was extra
oh
that's true that's true
in any case in any case
when we got we got the
the altair from
from uh mitz
uh we got i think number two
and um
we put it together fine you turn the
power on and it didn't get hot
so it was working
but there wasn't a whole lot you could
do
and that that eventually led to tiny
basic where he tried to build a
uh a basic which was
enough
to uh write small programs with and get
it into the machine and so uh
we
specified a language and within a couple
of weeks several people had implemented
it and uh the whole computer personal
computer business changed quite
radically because suddenly
or ordinary people could have computers
it actually
computed something
uh still wasn't really a
general purpose machine because
you needed more memory than you
you really had with 4k or 8k you needed
more
but it was the beginnings and it worked
pretty well
and um
[Music]
the
the problem of writing
small precise small coat
is was very hard
and so the 4004
this was i think contemporary with or
perhaps after the stuff that you had
done because i think
as i remember
as i remember intel was actually
shipping or making available via their
shared program stuff
your development system
um when i was working on the uh
the
mcs4
uh
system now mcs4 was a real computer
system it had
a
[Music]
it had it had a uh
a memory bus and uh
some some tools and some programs which
allowed you to do development uh on uh
uh on this on the unit with a paper tape
reader punch
uh which
which could be used to create real
programs
uh unlike what uh
we'll hear from ed
where
they uh they did the programming uh on
paper as i remember by hand and then
heated into the uh prom burner
the um
the stuff that i was doing uh was uh uh
specter rather simply uh it had to
duplicate what the
large scale system that ran on ibm
machines did exactly
and so the this ran in a large partition
of a dos
system
ibm dos
and was written in fortran it had a
gigantic
uh
parser
that was uh based on the latest theories
by uh klaus the earth
and uh it uh
it computed the uh
assembly instructions
by uh
by magic
it's it had a it had a
grammar and it was driven off the
grammar
um
any case it was big
lots bigger than the 4k i got and i had
to have a
a text
text editor and
paper tape editor
uh built in as well because it had to be
able to work standalone if i could chime
in for a minute you know the data point
2200 had removable magnetic tape
cassette and so i think one of the
realities of computers was do you have a
way of getting storage on and off the
cassette was an excellent choice
datapoint used the shift register as
main memory and you may recall that main
memory was expensive and the shift
register was cheap and available and
lastly i think to make a computer
interesting you needed a pretty good
printer and so i think the three things
that were
largely missing on early computers was
good printers good removable medium and
and certainly uh cheaper memory oh yeah
the the
the data point
machines had cassette memories as i
remember
removable cassettes yeah and what do you
say
well
it turns out that before we
started prologue
we did order entry systems for
supermarkets and we had the same
problems you guys had we solved it matt
and i
uh we had to come up with a paper with a
reader
uh printer and a keyboard
and we instrumented a victor adding
machine
we use yeah we use magnetic
read switches which we put underneath
along with a magnet
under each key and that that was the
keyboard and then the printer was the
victor which is 100 printer
and uh
that was all done in hardwired logic
um and that's the first application that
we had for the
uh 404 was replace it
and i'll make another comment you only
when you only have 4k of
instructions
it's not really worth the effort for an
engineer
to learn all that software gobbly
in order to just write a short program
of maybe you know 800
words or a thousand words to uh
or bytes i should say
uh to um
run the machine it's just uh
so that's why we taught assembly
language
um
and uh hexadecimal coding
and and that was done by hand so we
didn't have to have any compilers or
assemblers or anything like that
and debugging for an engineer was easy
because you'd find something wrong in io
that was mainly i o instructions
that people used and
you didn't see a signal and you go look
chase down
and one of the things i'll put out for
assembly language
as opposed to high level link which is
that you get to use all of the features
of the chip
in in high-level language which is
dominant now it has to be because it's
too complicated without it
uh
somebody's given up
a lot of features that that the hardware
has
in order to come up with a
a
fairly
modular
language
um so you know i'm just pointing out in
the old days this trade-off we weren't
the software people looked at us like we
were a bunch of morons but we taught
hundreds and hundreds of engineers how
to do software
faster than they could have learned to
use an assembler and a compiler and all
that other crap
um so uh that's why we did it and it
worked for 10 years
um
before that material got there
another thing i want to point out
earlier
stan
the reason the early computers had
morning sickness because i worked at
burroughs i started burrows in 58 okay
and the computers would have to run for
like a half hour before
the first was vacuum tube computers and
even the first solid statements
and the the problem was the carbon
composition resistors
which no longer exist
carbon copper resistors because i
designed a lot of hardware
would gather moisture during the evening
at night and they would the resistance
would change 10 to 20 percent
uh and when and most people didn't do
worse we did worst case design so that
our circuits worked right away but
most engineers didn't even know that
they just knew that
something in the machine had to run for
a while to heat it up so i just added
those little historical features to your
to your comments which i found really
enlightening
um
i'm blathering on now so
that's that's you see that's the uh
that's the uh the whole history and i
i'll second the fact that that you guys
uh uh
you and matt uh
trained a whole slew of engineers
in not so much programming as uh
hands-on logic design right that's
exactly what our point was you're not we
kept saying you're not doing programming
you're doing logic design
that's right and you know
in the early years of our workshops uh
matt matt sort of got a lot of noise
from the programming people myself
included we thought everything ought to
be done in a high level language but
over time we learned that in fact the
solution that uh
that you and matt came up with was uh
uh for the
some of the application space uh
definitely
different it was it was for
industrial control that was our whole
application space was i o
not
i'd like to hear from half for a minute
can you say a few words
i guess my my comments were
uh way back when
i worked for a company called american
regitel
and they made
um
point of sale terminals for um people
like macy's etc
and uh essentially a terminal had a
keyboard a printer and a serial link
okay and and i can't remember i think we
might have had an led readout but i'm
not sure
and
one of the projects i had
uh was it was designed with msi the
the machine they had and they wanted to
see if we could design um
the terminal logic compatibly uh with a
which i did um
i think the cost savings was such that
um they never actually went to
production with it it was cheaper but
not by enough to to ward all of the ramp
up in building it
uh a couple of other comments yeah i
used
octo
to program the damn thing
i cut my teeth on that and anyway
because i had designed that intel was
interested in me
and so i went to work for intel
and
i think they called it the microcomputer
development systems bill david
bill davidow had a group
and uh
the first project i had was the
intellect four
and then
let's see i guess the only other story i
can i
remember was in us wasn't that who did
the 40 40.
yeah i think i told you this story yeah
i think so
um
that
he was being transferred overseas and
the first chips came out
and i think i got first silicon a second
silicon and plugged it into an intellect
flow four to see if it would pass all
the checkers which it did
and he was delighted i guess when i let
him know that his part worked
because he didn't know
and you you had a
i don't know if you want me to talk
about the uh ice
oh yeah please do look at emulators but
we never did one uh i i first
told um
the group i worked in i could do an ice
uh
04 or an i-40
um
but they weren't interested in that so
much as the eight by that time the 8080
was out
and so i did think i think this thing
called the ice 80.
um which essentially um
it was a cable you could plug into the
socket where your 8080 uh would go
and you could use it for hardware and
software debugging
and
the main board of this ice system
plugged into what
we call the mds
microcomputer development system that
had the
multibus on it
and
one one with an 8080 processor
i don't know much more i can talk about
it but i guess the only other comments i
have is
the
when i had to present the idea to the
chip designers
they were all upset for two reasons
one the thing wouldn't go as fast as an
8080 would go
most people weren't trying to push the
speed of an 88 anyway who were doing
development
and the other one
they thought was even more serious
because the capacitive load on this
thing that i plugged in uh
was way higher than than the specs for
the 8080 and they thought well how could
you do that i said you only you're not
trying to build
a thousand of these things you're
plugging it into one system in order to
debug
your software and your hardware
and so
generally speaking it was some
trade-offs that worked
and it was used by i don't know how many
things i sold but it was a lot
we used it and one project did
i have it was magic
[Music]
it's it's it's it's it's one of the
the great hardware hacks of all time
and uh it was uh it was uh uh
well we never have completed the project
if we hadn't had it
yeah
and you know
and i guess i i learned that you needed
something like that from this project i
had with american rhizotel
because it ain't an active
to debug that thing
anyhow
well i you know one of the things i did
i i came to uh
to consulting uh from sri
and uh one of the things that
my consultancy did was uh
predict the future for various uh
folks
and i we had a client in france
that um
wanted to know what was going to happen
in the world in the next 25 years they
were doing their long-range planning
and it was it was it was kind of nice
that this was
subcontracted by howard bromberg
who
was one of the kobold
developers
and uh
the little team we put together involved
all the people at uh polymorphic which
was pretty interesting group of people
uh marcus byrock and uh
fred thorlin and a few others
and uh we uh we wrote what was uh pretty
much a uh
consensus
report
uh on what uh what this
little uh
french company who had a lot of money
wanted ought to do
uh we had seen the uh 4004 announcements
and we heard rumors of the 8008
we knew that gary kildahl was working on
a compiler for the 8080 and
we saw the handwriting on the wall
uh we'd watch the stuff at xerox park
where
the the uh
ethernet was uh
uh beginning to to be used and uh
long-ranged telecommunications was
improving and so forth
we cogitated a bit and decided that
what this french company should do is
they should just uh
buy into semiconductor processing they
should build themselves with fabs they
should
rethink their product lines to involve
uh
as few parts as possible and make them
all uh
semiconductor
processors and
they should interconnect everything with
this thing called ethernet
and so forth and so on so he wrote a
fairly you know extensive report
i wish i had a copy still
because
well it was it was it was
well thought through we spent a lot of
time on it
and then they wouldn't pay us
they said you know this is a fantasy
this is
this is not um not real
and we're not going to pay for it
uh
in many cases if you if you flash back
five years after the they said no i'm
paying paying for it
but that was the world we lived in
that we
had they done what we told them to do
they would have been a dominant factor
in the uh in the industry but
well you know the the the the vision is
not not there and you know
i can't i can't claim that the 4004
uh was in fact the vision
but it
certainly was open up to it to uh
to make other uh speculation make sense
that sort of thing
[Music]
you mentioned gary kildarlin and plm
actually i think a fair amount of the
code that went into the ice he was done
action in plm
well
i i decided that was a lot better than
[Laughter]
octal talking about competition just for
a moment if you don't mind uh of course
the 8080 was up against the 6800 from
motorola which was
which was an admirable chip and uh my
favorite example is a cash register i
think either
chip could be used in the cash register
very adequately yes a programmer could
certainly accommodate
one style of programming or one feature
over the other and the chips really had
a couple of different technical features
but i don't think it was too important
but one of my favorite experiences was
that i had um
while i was in europe for two years for
intel i presented to a very large
company
they were looking at decoding um push
buttons on the telephone and for private
branch exchange pbx so i wrote the code
for it i came in there with an intellect
and uh demonstrated the code running on
the
machine for them so i had done uh almost
a little bit too much as it turned out
this was erickson by the way well
um
my particular presentation said that
this 8080 was
10 times faster than the 6800 because
they had written a piece of code at
motorola on the job and the guy had done
it kind of sloppy and i had used even
what we could call some dirty tricks by
using some machine addresses so my code
was ten times faster well the erickson
people couldn't believe that so they
took apart what the motorola guy had
done and so that was a stupid way and
they put all their efforts into showing
that it couldn't really be ten times
slower than the 8080 and in the end
ericsson chose
the motorola chip
and so it was a lesson uh for me
that uh in making comparisons
uh
actually if you're
too much better or too good then it can
be thrown out so this is kind of a
little war story about uh in europe
motorola versus intel at ericsson
and they ended up choosing motorola
sure
well you know the
the the uh
all of the processors ended up with uh
with minor flaws and uh
you know the uh the
68 000 have had a
fairly significant flaw in the sense
that
it did not recover from interrupts very
well and so you couldn't write a uh
a
virtual memory system for the initial
version of the 68 000
and that was that was a big problem uh
solved by
very clever pieces of hardware built by
third parties
uh one simple one simply duplicated the
processor and ran the clocks in uh in uh
synchronous and when it encountered a
page full and it knew it was going to
encounter one and was able to do things
to recover from it
uh the ada has some had some
problems uh
which uh were actually the 8008 had some
problems in the sense that the on-ship
stack was uh a little shallow for uh
for programming
i'd like to speak to that point too
because it was amusing for me because
the
1620 had only one level of a call so in
the 4004 we had three levels of a call
which we thought would be super good now
that wasn't enough so when we went to
the 8008 we had let's say seven levels
of the call which would seem infinite
and then the
[Music]
8080 came along and what i learned and
this is interesting from marketing we
took the stack off of the chip so the
8080 had no stack and we said you can
use main memory for your stack so it's
unlimited so we actually made the chips
simpler took some stuff off of the chip
to make it cheaper and we could sell it
as a feature which was an advantage
which you have an unlimited stack so if
you follow the story one three seven and
then none none was better uh
uh for the customer
that's cool yes
when when i was doing the stuff on the
uh
the
original strategy to get things to fit
in 4 000 bytes involved uh
nested interpreters
and that
crashed and burned on not having only
four levels of uh
of stack
and ultimately uh uh
the actual assembler that i made
was written three times
uh the first time was trying to do that
sort of elegant solution
based on
uh conceptual
models of what we were trying to do
uh the second time was uh to do that
again in a slightly different way and
the third time was to say well
you just have to sit down and break the
problem into uh eight pieces because
that's the number of pages you had
and uh put each page then you
solve those
special problems that you assign to each
page
to the smallest possible
code that you can think of and use every
trick in the book and all of the
knowledge you have about how numbers
behave when they when you do this is and
that's to them
uh the hackman uh
tricks and the stuff that's in uh
uh in the hacker's delight
series of books that tank warren's done
and you know there are lots of places
you can use uh
properties of numbers that are not uh
not really obvious so sometimes the code
in the uh
the assembler looked very very strange
because it relied on
two's complement arithmetic
in ways that you don't normally expect
um
but that was that was the the way
way to do it that each if
you basically broke down this
system's problem of building an
assembler to the smallest possible
pieces and then force the assembler
to be as small as possible by making
each of the pieces as small as possible
and cheating everywhere
the division is the uh the best example
division is heart yeah you you just
circulated a while back a uh a short
paper on doing division with uh
microprocessors
and stan and uh
when i uh i did i read it i was thinking
about what i ended up doing
for the 4004
and
it was for an assembler and
division is a relatively rare operation
in the uh expressions that appear in
assembly
so we wrote the very simplest possible
uh
division system which simply took took
the number and decremented and counted
the number of times that you could put
one number in the other
and produce a
result and a uh a overflow
and
you could do that in
25 instructions or thereabouts as i
remember
and that was okay
because
nobody ever used division the in the in
the real world except
occasionally
and you you were successful in doing
that the fact it took a long time was uh
not important
uh doing um
one of the fancy division algorithms
however would never fit
in the uh in the system
let's guess if there any questions uh
anything that i had said or any comments
particularly that anybody wants to
follow up on
bran how about you
yeah brian you're muted
brian are you there
i don't know
yes sorry um uh i've been listening to
everything you've been doing and i'm
actually filling in a couple of gaps in
about three or four minutes i'll have a
presentation that i'd like to give that
will provide some um compliment or
information so give me just a couple
minutes
okay but i definitely have some
information here give me just a second
this is real time creation huh well yeah
i mean i i've just been listening what's
going on and i i see a couple things
that um
uh need um expansion here so that's
that's i'm doing this dynamically in
response to that so
i'm just about there
yeah i'm brian berg and um i've known
uh stan mazer for a number of years by
way the silver microcomputer workshop
and um i'm also in the ieee history
committee and also work on a lot of ieee
milestones here in silicon valley
and um
one one milestone that i knew really
needed um honoring was the 4004 so i
worked with stan mazer and ted hoff and
federico ferguin
and also did with laws of the computer
history museum
on a 4004 milestone to honor the um
this accomplishment we were going to
dedicate it this past november 15th
which is the 50th anniversary of the
4004 but because of covid that's
obviously um
has not happened uh it's gonna it's a
going to be honored with a bronze plaque
that will be installed at the um
robert noyce uh intel headquarters um on
mission college boulevard in santa clara
um so it'll either be out in front of
the building or it'll be in front of the
intel museum which is in the lobby of
that building
and so um that'll be dedicated hopefully
sometime this year but we'll just have
to see how it goes
but anyway i just wanted to
i'll tell you a little bit more about
milestones in just a moment but there's
a
couple of slides that i want to put up
just to kind of complete the picture
about the 4004 because we never actually
looked at one of the dips
during this discussion so this is one
that i had for my records
and so i just want to let you know what
the 14 pin 4004 dip looked like
then um
let's see
so i should be able to progress
through this um
let's see here we go
um so i took uh a couple of images from
a video that was actually created for
the mcs-4 um called the mcs4 story uh
stan mazer and ted hoff put this
together and so this is one of the
slides from it
and um
one of those um images within that video
shows the four pins for four dips so
these are the four thousand one two
three and four in in somebody's hand
maybe it was even either ted house or
stan lazer's hand i'm not sure but
anyway i just want to give a little bit
of reality some of the things we've done
by the
way is that okay thank you stan i
figured it was probably yours
and um here's the uh a bizicom um
calculator with the um all four of the
four thousand one two three and four
chips you can see in the lower part of
the um image there
so um we didn't actually see one of
these in the flashlight i think we saw
an image of a calculator but not the
actual one with the chips inside of it
so i thought that was a little bit of
reality to this
and also here's the building where all
the work was done 365 east middle field
road
just a little bit of context for
actually where the work was done
um and also there was a 50th anniversary
little glass plaque that was created and
you should have gotten one of these too
uh stan did you get one uh shipped with
you thank you yes
yeah so if you remember on that day in
last september at the computer history
museum remember i collected your
signature along with federico's and
ted's
so those those are scanned and you can't
quite see those but those are included
in the bottom this little glass plaque
that we have that honor the 50th
anniversary of the um chip
and thanks thanks for your efforts for
that too oh sure happy to do that so
also a little bit of background about
this ieee milestone program that i was
referencing it honors inventions and
accomplishments uh within ieee worldwide
about 220 have been dedicated um so far
and i've been involved with about 20 of
these in one way or another either
from scratch or involved with the
dedication
so um i'm i i really love this uh
milestone program it's been a lot of
neat things to honor accomplishments um
and uh here is the citation that is
going to be on the bronze plaque
for the 4004 um when it's dedicated so
in two
lengthy sentences i think it um really
summarizes what the 4004 accomplished uh
exactly i guess it's actually three
sentences but um anyway it
notes the fact that it's a single chip
device
and um uh
initially created for family calculating
machines
uh and so the single chip 4004 um has
created the industry model for the
microprocessor a key driver of the
digital information age
so in these approximately 68 words the
um 4004 uh is being honored as a
milestone
um
now these now these milestone plaques um
there's a there's a bronze plaque a 12
by 18 inch plaque that uh is created
if you go to the computer history museum
and
the brick wall that
is right by the front entryway you'll
see what are now actually 13 plaques
there's an event that i organized uh
last september uh the third person from
the left is federico
he spoke about a couple of the plaques
there and stan was there along with ted
hoff
and um anyway if you go to that brick
wall you'll see these plaques three more
have since been added for the apple one
apple ii and macintosh
those are yet to be officially dedicated
but um it's the largest assemblage of
these ieee milestone plaques world there
at the museum
and um here's a little close-up of one
of them this is the first one that was
um dedicated there at the museums
actually for the museum itself kind of
see what the what the plaque actually
looks like
so just give you a little bit of
background about this i triple milestone
program and how i've gotten to know ted
and stan and federico quite well
particularly with regards to this 4004
um
milestone that hopefully sometime later
this year we'll be dedicated
so that's my little bit
great
thanks brian
sure
the uh
the ieee program has been very
very entertaining and i think
educational
and uh really appreciate the time that
you put into making it work
uh we know that just
i know how much time it takes to
make one of these things actually happen
and it's uh it's uh
it seems
well
when i was doing that sort of thing it
seemed like it was
infinite
infinite black hole into which you could
spend as much time as you wanted and not
necessarily get out
well i i've kind of turned it into a
science frankly i i know what it takes
to do this
i've seen a lot of people propose these
um and i've been a i triple history
committee meetings and seen the wording
of the citation kind of picked apart i'm
happy to say
that the precise wording that i proposed
for this with help from of course all
three of the um designers
along with um
dag spicer at the museum
and
a number of other people it was not a
single word was changed in the citation
because we had worked it out so
precisely so i'm very happy
about that that it it came through
exactly as proposed
brian you probably want to kill that
image so it comes okay
yup yup i will do that and we'll do that
there we go yeah okay there it is
well i i think that we're pretty much
out of time here i do want to thank you
all for your participation
um i don't know about the rest of you
but i thought that it was uh really uh
i just delightful to
revisit uh
uh
50 years ago and
think of all of this thing uh and and to
sit down i i thought about all the
people that i had met in the process of
doing my work at intel and uh
i it was uh it was really uh
uh
very formative and
you know you all have had some
some very uh
significant impact on what i learned how
to do so i thank you thank you for that
and it was uh nice to find the few
people that i hadn't talked to in ages
are still around and still doing
interesting things that's you happened
and uh and uh
well actually all of you and you know
tom i've seen uh some uh some and uh
some of them uh
also um
uh
stan but uh
ed edley i had not seen for 50 years and
uh
it turns out he's still the same kind of
guy he was before competent and
interesting
thanks ed
by the way one more little comment
intel has agreed to purchase a duplicate
4004 plaque so it will indeed be on that
wall of the museum as well
cool okay
yep great
anyhow thank you all very much
you